I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hi Angela. Hello lady. We're not in the studio together today, are we? We're not. But you look like you're in a fancy studio. I am in the fancy New York offices of Stitcher. Get out. You're in New York City. Yeah. And guess what lady? What? Guess what? What? Our picture is on the wall here. In New York? Yes. In the New York offices. They have our Office ladies picture on the
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯尼。我们一起演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。嗨，安吉拉。你好，女士。我们今天没有一起在录音室里，对吧？是的。但你看上去像是在一个很高级的录音室里。我的确在 Stitcher 位于纽约的高级办公室里。少来。你在纽约市。对。你猜怎么着，女士？什么？猜怎么着？什么？我们的照片就挂在这里的墙上。在纽约？是的。在纽约办公室。他们把我们的《办公室女士》的照片挂在
wall. I took a picture with it. Ah, that's so cool. I know. We have photos in two cities. In two cities. That's the big time. We're bicoastal. Right now. Wait a second. Right now we're bicoastal. Office ladies has gone bicoastal. That feels real boss lady. It does. I like it. Me too. Well, since we're talking about being in offices, Jenna, guess who's back at Dunder Mifflin? Toby. Well, not everybody's happy about it. No, God. No, God, please no. No. No. No. That's right. Today we are talking about frame Toby. It is season five, episode nine. It is written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Jason Reitman. That's a good duo. I'm going to give you a summary. I was hoping you would. Michael reacts poorly to
墙上了。我还跟它合了影。啊，太酷了。我知道。我们在两个城市都有照片。在两个城市。这可是大场面。我们跨海岸了。现在。等等。现在我们跨海岸了。《办公室女士》已经跨海岸了。这感觉真有老板的范儿。确实。我很喜欢。我也是。好吧，既然我们在聊办公室的事，珍娜，你猜谁回到了邓德米弗林？托比。好吧，并不是所有人都为此高兴。不，老天。不，老天，求你了，别。不。不。不。没错。今天我们要聊的是“陷害托比”。这是第五季第九集。由明蒂·卡灵编剧，杰森·雷特曼执导。真是个优秀的二人组。我来给你做个总结。我正希望你这么做呢。迈克尔的反应很糟糕，
the revelation that Toby is back at the Scranton branch. I like the use of the word poorly. I know. That's an understatement. So he and Dwight hatch a plan to frame Toby for drugs that Michael has purchased from the two Vance refrigeration employees, Geno and Leo. Pam is incensed by a mess that is left in the microwave by one of her co-workers. We don't know who. She leaves a pointed note, which elicits mixed reactions from the fellow employees. Meanwhile, Ryan breaks up with Kelly and Jim surprises Pam with the news that he bought his parents' house for them. That's a lot. It's a lot. These headphones are tight. The headphones are tight in New York. I fixed them. Do you want a different pair? No, I
得知托比回到了斯克兰顿分公司。我喜欢“糟糕”这个词。我知道。这简直是轻描淡写。所以他和德怀特密谋陷害托比，把毒品栽赃到托比头上，而毒品是迈克尔从两个万斯制冷公司的员工吉诺和利奥那里买来的。帕姆对同事在微波炉里留下的烂摊子气愤不已。我们不知道是谁。她留下一张尖锐的字条，引发了同事们的复杂反应。与此同时，瑞安和凯利分手了，吉姆给帕姆带来了一个惊喜，告诉她他把父母的房子买下来送给他们。信息量真大。信息量真大。这耳机真紧。纽约的耳机真紧。我调好了。你想换一副吗？不，我
fixed them. Okay. You guys, that was Jared in New York. Yeah. Jared is the Sam of New York. Yeah. Sam, say hi. Little dig at LA there in our loose headphones. Why? I like some loose. I like a loose headphone. Oh, in that case, take that Jared. Jared's all squeeze in my brain with the headphones here in New York. Should we go into fast facts? I think we should. All right. Fast fact number one, you might remember because we shared this earlier that NBC ordered 28 episodes for season five. It was our longest season. I remember, Geno, when we wrapped season five, we all got sick. Oh, yeah. Like we all got the flu or something because I remember the next week, like texting a few people. I'm like, I have
调好了。各位，那是纽约的杰瑞。对。杰瑞就是纽约的山姆。对。山姆，打个招呼。洛杉矶那边对我们松垮耳机的暗讽。为什么？我喜欢松一点的。我喜欢松垮的耳机。哦，既然这样，接招吧，杰瑞。杰瑞的耳机把我在纽约的脑子都快夹扁了。我们要进入趣味冷知识环节吗？我觉得应该。好的。趣味冷知识一，你可能还记得，因为我们之前分享过，NBC 为第五季订购了 28 集。这是我们最长的一季。我记得，吉诺，当我们拍完第五季时，我们都病倒了。哦，对。就像我们都得了流感什么的，因为我记得第二周，我还给几个人发短信。我说，我感冒
a cold. Okay. It was like, yeah, me too. Like I think our bodies were just like. Yeah. A standard network television season usually runs on television from September to May. We work from July to March, right? So that we can get the episodes ready. And a standard television schedule is usually where you do three weeks on one week off of filming. So usually a show will take one hiatus week a month, but the writers always continue to work for that week. That week off is meant so that the writers and the producer, they have a sort of catch up week because they're constantly writing, prepping, editing, delivering the episodes. They would have these episodes in multiple forms. They're like doing an
了。好吧。就像，对，我也是。我觉得我们的身体当时就像是……对。标准的网络电视季通常从九月播到次年五月。我们从七月工作到三月，对吧？这样我们才能把剧集准备好。而标准的电视播出安排通常是拍摄三周，休息一周。所以通常剧组一个月会有一个停拍周，但编剧们在那一周总是继续工作。那一周的休息是为了让编剧和制作人有一个类似补进的星期，因为他们一直在写作、筹备、剪辑、交付剧集。他们会同时处理好几种形式的剧集。他们可能在写这一集的
outline for one, but they're writing another. They're punching up another one. They're doing post editing on another one. They've got like five episodes going at once. We would just be like, what are we filming this week? Right. This year, with this crazy 28 episode season, Steve Carell also had a commitment to do a film. I think it was Get Smart. And he needed like a six to eight week break from the show in the middle of that July to March filming schedule so he could film Get Smart. How did we ever do that? In order to do that, we had to film 19 episodes in a row. That's when we got sick. That's when we got sick. I just have a memory of a bunch of us getting a cold buck. That was it. Yeah. So frame Toby was
大纲，但在写另一集的剧本。他们还在润色另一集。他们在对另一集进行后期剪辑。他们同时在推进大约五集。我们当时只会问，我们这周拍什么？对。今年，由于这疯狂的 28 集，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔还承接了一部电影的拍摄。我想那是《糊涂侦探》。在七月到三月的拍摄周期中间，他需要大约六到八周的假去拍《糊涂侦探》。我们当年是怎么做到的？为了做到这一点，我们不得不连续拍摄 19 集。就是那时候我们病倒了。就是那时候我们病倒了。我只记得我们一大群人一起感冒了。就是这样。对。所以“陷害托比”就
right in the middle of this crazy 19 episode schedule. And here's why I think this is significant. It's really crazy to me that they decided to bring Toby back in the middle of this 19 episode stretch. Because remember, he was now our showrunner because Greg was doing Parks and Rec. So Paul Lieberstein is now showrunning and acting in an episode. Again, because they gave him that break. And now they're like, sorry, bud, you need to be Toby again. You're back in the mix. So I reached out to Jen Salada who was running the show with him. And I said, do you know why you did that? Did you just want Paul to never sleep? What was your plan there? And she said, she can't remember exactly the
在这个疯狂的 19 集拍摄周期的正中间。这就是为什么我认为这很重要。我觉得很疯狂的是，他们竟然决定在这个 19 集的长跑中间把托比带回来。因为记住，他现在是我们的剧集运作人了，因为格雷格在做《公园与游憩》。所以保罗·李伯斯坦现在既要运作剧集，还要在一集中演戏。同样是因为他们给了他那个假期。现在他们又说，对不起，老兄，你得重新当托比了。你又回到这个圈子里了。所以我联系了和他在共同运作剧集的珍·萨拉达，我问，你知道你为什么要这么做吗？你是想让保罗永远不用睡觉吗？你当时有什么计划？她说，她记不清具体的原因了，
reasoning, but because Holly had left, they were either going to have to cast someone new or bring Toby back. And that dynamic between Toby and Michael was so beloved. She said, as a fan of the show, she wanted Toby to come back to that role. As a co-showrunner, she was freaked out at the idea of Paul having to wear both hats. But she said he did it so well. And Paul said he doesn't remember sleeping a lot. Aw. But also, he enjoyed doing it. You know, he liked his time on set with us. Well, I love Toby coming back just because watching Michael spiral is delicious. This is one of my favorite episodes of the season for that reason. So thank you, Paul, for doing that. We're Paul, but thank you.
但因为霍利已经离开，他们要么得选个新演员，要么得把托比带回来。而托比和迈克尔之间的那种化学反应太受欢迎了。她说，作为这部剧的粉丝，她希望托比回到那个角色中。作为联合剧集运作人，一想到保罗必须兼顾两头，她就感到恐慌。但她说他做得太棒了。保罗说他记不得自己有没有睡过觉。噢。不过，他也乐在其中。你知道的，他很享受和我们在片场的时光。好吧，我喜欢托比回来，仅仅是因为看迈克尔抓狂太让人大快朵颐了。出于这个原因，这是我这一季最喜欢的剧集之一。所以谢谢你，保罗，谢谢你这么做。我们是保罗，但谢谢。
My fast fact number two is a big thank you to James Carey because he gave us the shooting draft for frame Toby. Yes, James. This was so fun to watch it with the shooting draft. Jenna and I were texting each other and calling each other like, oh my God, that's not in. But this is, but did you see that? It was really fun. And this is a particularly amazing episode to have the script for because this microwave runner, the dirty microwave runner, it was much bigger in the original script. Yes. And it was full of Angela and Pam stuff. Yes. So we get to share about all that today. So thank you, James Carey. Thank you, James Carey. We are also going to have some great location details. Thanks to Randy Cordray.
我的趣味冷知识二要大大感谢詹姆斯·凯瑞，因为他给我们提供了“陷害托比”的拍摄剧本。是的，詹姆斯。拿着拍摄剧本看这一集太有趣了。我和珍娜互相发短信打电话说，哦天哪，那段没拍进去。但这段有，你看到了吗？真的很有趣能拿到剧本，尤其是这一集，因为微波炉这条线，那个脏微波炉的故事线，在原剧本里要宏大得多。是的。而且全都是安吉拉和帕姆的戏份。是的。所以我们今天可以把这些都分享出来。所以谢谢你，詹姆斯·凯瑞。谢谢你，詹姆斯·凯瑞。我们还将有一些极棒的外景细节。多亏了兰迪·科德雷。
He told me all about Jim and Pam's new house. And I have to share something that Randy said in his email to me when I reached out to him about this episode. Are you ready? Okay. Yes. He said, a particular delight of looking forward to your questions each week is that I get to revisit each episode to refresh my memory of what we collectively accomplished. Here's what his process is when I write him an email. Oh, he says, my process is to reread the shooting draft, watch the episode, watch any deleted scenes and listen to any commentary that might have been recorded. Randy, this is what I do every week. This is what Jen and I are doing. That's what I said. I said, you are an office lady. You are an office
他把所有关于吉姆和帕姆新房子的事都告诉我了。当我就这一集联系兰迪时，我必须分享一些他在邮件里对我说的话。准备好了吗？好的。是的。他说，期待你们每周提出的问题的一种特别乐趣是，我可以重新温习每一集，刷新我对我们共同成就的记忆。以下是当我给他写邮件时他的流程。哦，他说，我的流程是重读拍摄剧本，看这一集，看任何删减片段，并听任何可能录制过的评论音轨。兰迪，这就是我每周都在做的事。这也是我和珍娜正在做的事。我就是这么说的。我说，你就是一个办公室女士。你就是一个办公室
lady. And Jenna, every time you email him a question now, I'm going to be like, don't ask him that. I don't want to send him down a rabbit hole. I know, but he really said he's really been liking it. And remember when our podcast for weight loss came out and Randy wrote us that night's email, he wrote us the most lovely email. Yeah. He was just like, ladies, you nailed it. You got every bit of information that could be known about how we did that engagement scene with the rain and the parking lot. I'm so proud of you too. I know. It was like we got an email from our dad. That's how I felt. Like dad thought we did a good job. I know. I want Randy's respect. I do too, because I respect him.
女士。珍娜，以后每次你发邮件问他问题，我都得说，别问他那个。我可不想把他带进兔子洞里。我知道，但他真的说他非常喜欢。还记得我们的减肥播客上线的那天晚上，兰迪给我们写了封邮件吗，他给我们写了一封最可爱的邮件。对。他当时就说，女士们，你们太棒了。关于我们是怎么拍那个带雨景和停车场的求婚场景的，所有能知道的信息你们都挖出来了。我也为你们感到骄傲。我知道。感觉就像我们收到了爸爸发来的邮件。我当时就是这种感觉。就像爸爸觉得我们做得很好。我知道。我想要兰迪的尊重。我也是，因为我很尊重他。
Look what he's doing just off an email of questions. We got to have him on the show. He's got to come on. He's an office lady. We need to have Randy and James come on. Yes. Because they worked together. Okay. Future revisited everybody. Did you hear that, Randy and James? I guess that's my serious tone. What am I doing? Did you hear that? You're coming on the pod, fellas. I'm going to move us into fast fact number three. Okay. I think the world is going to be grateful for this fast fact because I was grateful for it. Oh no. Somebody did a deep dove. This is how to clean a microwave. Oh Lord. This episode's about dirty microwaves and I thought how could we clean this microwave? This episode is about
看看他只是回个邮件解答问题就做了这么多。我们得请他上节目。他必须得来。他是个办公室女士。我们需要请兰迪和詹姆斯上节目。是的。因为他们一起工作过。好吧，大家注意了，未来回顾。听到了吗，兰迪和詹姆斯？我想这就是我的严肃语调。我在干什么？听到了吗？你们要上播客了，伙计们。我要把大家带入趣味冷知识三。ok。我觉得全世界都会感谢这个趣味冷知识，因为我很感激它。哦，不。有人做了一次深度钻研。这就是如何清洗微波炉。哦，天哪。这一集是关于脏微波炉的，我想我们怎么才能清洗这个微波炉？这一集是关于
dirty microwaves. All right. Ainsley Bubaco, our associate producer, helped me with this and I love it. Here is how to clean a real dirty microwave. Okay. All right. Get a microwave safe bowl. Fill it with two cups of water and two tablespoons of vinegar. Now side note, if you'd like, you could add a drop of your favorite essential oil if you want. If you want to be fancy. Yeah. You can clean your microwave fancy or regular. Okay. Now turn the microwave on, obviously put the bowl in the microwave and then put it on high for five minutes. You want it to get real steamy in there. Okay. That's what she said. Mm-hmm. After it's done, don't open the microwave door for 15 minutes. Why? Because you'll burn
脏微波炉的。好吧。埃恩斯利·布巴科，我们的副制片人，帮了我这个忙，我太喜欢了。以下是清洗真正的脏微波炉的方法。好的。好吧。拿一个微波炉专用的碗。里面装两杯水和两汤匙白醋。顺便说一句，如果你愿意，如果你想讲究一点，可以加一滴你最喜欢的精油。如果你想精致一点。对。你可以把微波炉洗得很精致或者很普通。好的。现在打开微波炉，当然要把碗放进微波炉里，然后高火加热五分钟。你想让里面充满蒸汽。好的。她就是这么说的。嗯哼。加热结束后，先不要打开微波炉门 15 分钟。为什么？因为你会
yourself or something? No, because that makes all the baked on grime sort of softened. Oh. And then you can wipe it off? Yeah. That's step three. Wipe it off. Just wipe it out. Done. Your microwave is clean. You're welcome. You're welcome. That's it. We can go to break. You can clean your microwave while you listen to some advertisements. Or if you're listening on Stitcher Premium, you won't have time to clean your microwave because it's ad-free. Oh. Well, let's take a break because Jenna just told me the bathrooms in New York are real far from where you're sitting. They are and you need a key. Oh. Yeah. Well, in LA, it's a porta-potty on the side of the road. So I'm going to go now. I'm kidding. Sam is
烫伤自己什么的？不，因为那会让所有烤焦的污垢变软。哦。然后你就可以把它擦掉了？对。第三步就是擦掉。直接擦干净。大功告成。你的微波炉干净了。不用谢。不用谢。就是这样。我们可以去休息了。你可以在听广告的同时清理你的微波炉。或者如果你在 Stitcher Premium 上收听，你将没有时间清理你的微波炉，因为它是无广告的。哦。好吧，我们休息一下吧，因为珍娜刚刚告诉我，纽约的洗手间离你坐的地方真的很远。确实很远，而且你需要一把钥匙。哦。好吧，在洛杉矶，那是一个路边的流动厕所。所以我要去了。开玩笑的。山姆在
applauding. All right, guys, we'll be right back. We'll be right back. Well, we are back and everyone's real excited because there's brownies in the conference room. Every time I worked in an office and someone brought in a baked good, it was the whole exciting moment. Heck, yeah. I loved it. We're not sure why there are brownies, but everyone's real happy about it. It's true. We had a fan question from Jessica L that says, why are there brownies in the conference room at the beginning of the episode? Was it someone's birthday? And then Jessica would like to know, did Angela bring the brownies? Because we've heard a lot of references to Angela's famous brownies. Yeah. Well, I looked at the script. Yeah. Because I had it. That's
鼓掌。好了，各位，我们马上回来。我们马上回来。好吧，我们回来了，每个人都很兴奋，因为会议室里有布朗尼蛋糕。每当我在办公室工作时，只要有人带来烘焙点心，那绝对是一个令人兴奋的时刻。真的，太对了。我太喜欢了。我们不确定为什么会有布朗尼蛋糕，但每个人都为此高兴坏了。确实如此。我们有一个来自杰西卡·L的粉丝提问，上面写着，为什么在这一集开始时会议室里会有布朗尼蛋糕？是某人的生日吗？然后杰西卡想知道，是安吉拉带来的布朗尼吗？因为我们听过很多关于安吉拉著名的布朗尼蛋糕的传说。是的。好吧，我看了剧本。是的。因为我有剧本。没错。
right. It says Phyllis is giving away brownies, but there is no further explanation as to why. But it does make a note that Angela is not eating the brownies. Yeah. In the script, Pam is like, Angela, why aren't you having any? Yeah. Pam, a little bit of a s*** stir. Andy says she's dieting. My baby's trying to fit into a child-size wedding gown for our big day. Ugh. And Jim says, why? And why do those exist? Yeah. And then Angela says, it's from my pageant days. I was Miss Tiny Mid-Atlantic Bride when I was 10. What? Was Angela's childhood? I don't know. Seriously. And you guys remember, this is a callback. Remember performance review season two, Angela had a talking head where she said, and I quote,
上面写着菲利斯在发布朗尼，但没有进一步解释原因。不过剧本里确实备注了安吉拉没有吃布朗尼。是的。在剧本里，帕姆说，安吉拉，你怎么不吃一点？是的。帕姆，有点像个爱挑事的人。安迪说她在减肥。我的小心肝正在努力塞进儿童码的婚纱，为了我们的盛大婚礼。呃。吉姆说，为什么？为什么这东西会存在？是的。然后安吉拉说，这是我选美时期的习惯。我 10 岁时曾是“迷你大西洋中部新娘”。什么？安吉拉的童年到底经历过什么？我不知道。说真的。你们还记得吗，这是一个前情回溯。还记得第二季的绩效评估，安吉拉有一个单人访谈，她说，我原话引述：
I actually look forward to performance reviews. I did the Youth Beauty Pageant Circuit, and I enjoyed that quite a bit. I really enjoy being judged. I believe I hold up very well even to severe scrutiny. Well, we know that you won Miss Tiny Mid-Atlantic Bride when you were 10. And that's my wedding dress. There it is. I wonder how many more of these that you won. I wonder, were you a big winner in your mind as the character of Angela? Do you think she won quite often? Yes. I think that Angela Martin like peaked at 13. Okay. Like she was it. She won all of like the young pageant, junior pageant, and then she retired. I see. Okay. Let us move on. While we're in the conference room, Kelly is going to take
我其实很期待绩效评估。我参加过青少年选美比赛，我挺享受那个的。我真的很享受被人评判。我相信即使面对严苛的审视，我也经受得住。好吧，我们知道你 10 岁时赢得了“迷你大西洋中部新娘”。那就是我的婚纱。就是这样。我想知道你还赢了多少次这种比赛。我想知道，作为安吉拉这个角色，你在心里觉得自己是个常胜将军吗？你觉得她赢得挺频繁的吗？是的。我觉得安吉拉·马丁在 13 岁时就达到了颜值和人生巅峰。好吧。就像她就是最棒的。她赢了所有那种少年选美、青年选美的奖，然后就退休了。我明白了。好吧。让我们继续。当我们在会议室时，凯利拿了
two brownies. One for Toby. Right. And Michael kind of scoffs at this, but nobody else seems to think it's a joke. Yeah. He calls her a weirdo. He's like, whatever weirdo. I know. And Jim is like, Michael, Toby is back. And Michael's like, okay. And so he walks back to the annex and no one's there. But then suddenly someone is there and it is Toby. It is Toby. I want you guys to know at one minute, 23 seconds, is Michael turns to see Toby and he has that look of horror in his face. If you look at the wall behind him, you will see that there are three framed sort of things on the wall for Toby. There is an award for Toby Flindersen, a certificate of achievement, and a diploma from the California
两块布朗尼。一块给托比。对。迈克尔对此有点嘲讽，但其他人似乎并不觉得这是个笑话。是的。他叫她怪胎。他就像，随便吧，怪胎。我知道。吉姆说，迈克尔，托比回来了。迈克尔说，好吧。于是他走回办公区，发现那里没有人。但突然间有人在那儿了，那就是托比。就是托比。我想让大家知道，在 1 分 23 秒时，迈克尔转身看到托比，他脸上有那种惊恐的表情。如果你看他身后的墙，你会看到墙上有三个框起来的东西是给托比的。有一个托比·弗林德森的奖状、一份成就证书，还有一张来自加州
Coastal College. So Jenna, he had been back long enough to hang up his framed items. And in the script, Toby had a talking head where he said this, I've been back for six days. I think I've even talked to him. I wish that stayed in me too. I wish so much it had stayed in. For my background catch folks, the California Coastal College, I don't think that's a thing. I googled it. I couldn't find it. I did find the California Coast University, which is a private online university based in Santa Ana, California. Oh, there you go. My background people. Well, we got a lot of fan mail. People wanted to know if Michael's screaming no and all of that was improvised or if it was in the script. In the script, it just says Michael
海岸学院的毕业证。所以珍娜，他回来已经够久了，把他的框装物品都挂上了。在剧本里，托比有一个单人访谈，他是这么说的，我回来已经六天了。我想我甚至跟他说过话了。我真希望这段也被保留下来。我太希望这段能保留了。对于我的背景考据达人们，那个加州海岸学院，我觉得没这所学校。我谷歌过了。我没找到。我找到了加州海岸大学，那是一所总部位于加州圣安娜的私立在线大学。哦，原来如此。我的背景考据达人们。好吧，我们收到了很多粉丝来信。人们想知道迈克尔大喊“不”以及所有这些是即兴发挥还是剧本里写的。在剧本里，只写着迈克尔
turns and screams in all caps. Yeah. But that whole like, no, no, God, no, that was Steve. That was Steve's interpretation of that script note. And how funny was that? You guys, if you read that you scream, I think most of us would just be like, right? Yes. But Steve made a meal out of that moment. In the best way. He's a comedy genius. Yes. You know, Screen Rant did a list of the top 15 pop culture references created by the office and the meme of Steve saying no is one of them. I don't doubt it. I have been online where I see people that I don't even know, like respond to other people with just Steve's face going, no. It's anything. Well, the episode starts and Michael is spiraling. He's going to call David Wallace.
转身尖叫，全是全大写字母。是的。但整段像“不，不，老天，不”，那是史蒂夫的发挥。那是史蒂夫对那个剧本提示的诠释。那有多搞笑？各位，如果你读到剧本说你尖叫，我想我们大多数人都会只是，啊？对吧？是的。但史蒂夫把那一刻演绎得淋漓尽致。以最棒的方式。他是个喜剧天才。是的。你知道，Screen Rant 曾列出由《办公室》创造的流行文化参考前 15 名，史蒂夫说“不”的那个表情包就是其中之一。我对此毫不怀疑。我在网上看到过，有些甚至我不认识的人，在回复别人的时候只用史蒂夫说“不”的脸。任何时候都用。好吧，这一集开始了，迈克尔开始抓狂了。他要打电话给大卫·华尔士。
He's watching Stupid Toby as he shows us stupid photos of Costa Rica to Phyllis. Yeah. He manages to get David on the phone by texting him 911. Call me. But you know what? Michael said he's learned that people will not return his calls unless he texts 911. And now everybody does because they think something horrible has happened. So I had a pager when I first got to LA. So did I. You had to because you didn't like really have cell phones. You had a pager. And the only reason you had a pager was so that your agent could page you if you got an audition. And then you would have to go find a phone. You'd have to find a pay phone. Call them back. Yeah. I used to keep a Ziploc bag full of change in my car for
他看着愚蠢的托比向菲利斯展示那些愚蠢的哥斯达黎加照片。是的。他通过发短信“911，请给我回电话”成功让大卫接了电话。但你知道吗？迈克尔说他吸取了教训，如果他不发“911”，人们是不会回他电话的。现在每个人都回了，因为他们以为发生了什么可怕的事。所以当我刚到洛杉矶时，我有一个寻呼机。我也是。你必须得有，因为你当时其实没有手机。你有一个寻呼机。你拥有寻呼机的唯一原因就是如果你的经纪人帮你争取到一个试镜机会，他可以呼你。然后你得去找一部电话。你得找个公用电话。回电话给他。对。我以前在车里放了一个装满零钱的自封袋，
two reasons. One for all of the metered parking that didn't accept credit cards, just coins. And two so that I could find a pay phone and call my agent back when my agent paged me, which was maybe twice a year. Oh, yeah. I remember one time distinctly I was driving through Santa Monica with some friends and my pager went off and I almost swerved off the road. My career is happening. I've hit the big time. I've been paged. We were supposed to be going to the beach. I was like, no, we can't do that now. I have to find a pay phone. So we're all like driving the streets looking for a pay phone. I pulled over. I ran up to the pay phone. I put my quarters in, called them and they were like, all right,
原因有二。第一，为了所有不接受信用卡、只收硬币的计时停车位。第二，这样当我的经纪人呼我时，我可以找到一部公用电话给经纪人回电，一年大概也就两次吧。哦，对。我清楚地记得有一次我和几个朋友开车穿过圣莫尼卡，我的寻呼机响了，我差点把车开出路面。我的职业生涯要腾飞了。我迎来大场面了。我被呼了。我们本打算去海滩的。我当时就想，不，我们现在不能去了。我得找个公用电话。于是我们都在街上开车找公用电话。我把车停在路边。我跑向公用电话。我投进硬币，打过去，他们说，好吧，你戴过什么眼镜吗？我说，什么？没有。他们说，我们有个伦斯克拉夫特眼镜的试镜。他们想找戴眼镜的人。我说，那不是我。好吧，拜拜。是的，差不多就是这样。不过后来我有过一个男朋友，他当时不回我电话。你点亮那个寻呼机了吗？我当然点亮了，发了一堆 911。你懂的。你真的这么做了？哦，对。哦，对。我做了。你是个神经质女友吗？你知道吗？他那天晚上背着我偷腥。哦，所以你知道。你知道。我知道。我们之后就分手了。哦，天哪。是的，我不会去点亮寻呼机。我坐在这里叫你神经质。我不会去点亮寻呼机，但我会开车过去
have you ever needed any kind of glasses? I'm like, what? No. And they're like, we have an audition for you for Lens Crafters. They would like people who wear glasses. I'm like, that's not me. All right, bye. Yeah, that's pretty much it. But then I did have a boyfriend once who was not calling me back. Did you light up that pager? I sure did with a bunch of 911s. You know it. Did you really? Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. I did. Were you a psycho girlfriend? You know what? He was cheating on me that night. Oh, so you knew. You knew. I knew it. We broke up after that. Oh, man. Yeah, I wouldn't light up the pager. I'm like sitting here calling you psycho. I wouldn't light up the pager, but I would drive over
然后像这样藏在灌木丛里。这比发短信“911”要复杂得多。我的计划是这样的。我想，我知道他在背着我偷腥。所以我要点亮那个寻呼机让它震动，这样当他们在做任何他们正在做的事时，寻呼机就会一直响，好吧，我就是要毁了他们的好时光。他可能只是把它关机了。我想我大概只能从灌木丛里跳出来说，嘿，你们在干什么？抓到了吧。现在我要回家了，因为我头发上沾了树枝，我很尴尬。这是妈妈侦探的情节吗？我们应该把“妈妈侦探”设定在那个只有寻呼机和藏在灌木丛里的过去吗？对。哦，藏在灌木丛里。哦，那可能别有一番风味。
and like hide out in a bush. That's so much more elaborate than texting 911. Here was my plan. I was like, I know he's cheating on me. So I'm going to light up that pager and make it buzz so that while they're whatever they're doing, the pagers just like, yeah, I'm just going to ruin their good time. He probably just turned it off. I guess I'm just going to jump out of a bush and be like, Hey, what are you doing? Gotcha. Now I'm going to go home because I've got twigs in my hair and I'm embarrassed. Is this a plot line for mom detectives? Should we set mom detectives in the past where all we have are pagers and bush hiding? Yes. Oh, bush hiding. Oh, that could be something else.
这有什么不对的？我们可以叫它“灌木丛隐蔽者”吗？不行。我们不能。这根本说不通。这根本说不通。你去推销它吧。嗨，我们的节目。它叫“灌木丛隐蔽者”。如果你不想买，那你可真没眼光，因为这绝对是金子。他们会问，这是讲什么的？我们会说，这是两个妈妈侦探。是两个穿着舒服衣服的老年妇女。对，我们不穿任何名牌服装。我们想要那种 30 分钟的服装造型环节。衣服不会是合身的。我们想要很多看剧的人根本不会真正理解的老旧科技。我们要藏在一些灌木丛里。对。你要买吗？好吧，我们在哪儿？我们不应该在节目里分享这个，因为会有人把它偷走的。我向你保证，两年后，你打开 HBO Max，就会看到两个 20 岁的人主演一部名叫《灌木丛隐蔽者》的剧。记住我的话。记住我的话。
What's wrong with this? Can we call it bush hiders? No. We can't. It doesn't even make any sense. It doesn't make any sense. You go pitch it. Hi, our show. It's called bush hiders. And if you don't want to buy it, you're a natural because this is gold. And they're like, what's it about? And we're like, it's two mom detectives. It's two older women and comfortable clothing. Yeah, we're not wearing any designer clothes. We want like 30 minute wardrobe sessions. It won't be fitted. And we want a lot of old tech that no one watching it will really understand. And we're going to hide in some bushes. Yeah. Do you want it? Okay, where are we? We shouldn't have shared that on the air because someone's
这有什么不对的？我们叫它“灌木丛藏身者”行吗？不行。我们不能这么叫。这根本说不通。这根本说不通。你去推销试试。嗨，我们的节目。名字叫“灌木丛藏身者”。如果你不想买单，那你可真是个天才，因为这绝对是摇钱树。然后他们会问，这是讲什么的？我们就说，这是两个妈妈侦探。是两个穿着舒服衣服的老年妇女。对，我们不穿任何名牌服装。我们需要大约30分钟的服装准备时间。服装不会是修身的。我们还需要很多正在看节目的观众根本不会真正理解的老旧科技。然后我们要藏在灌木丛里。对。你们想要吗？好了，我们现在在哪？我们真不该在节目里说这个，因为有人会
going to steal it. I guarantee you in two years, you're going to turn on HBO Max and there's going to be two 20 year old starring in a show called bush hiders. Mark my word. Mark my word. And they're going to be young, hot detectives and designer clothes. That's how it works in this business. That's right. I'm not jaded. All right. Should we move on? What's happened to me in New York? Who am I here? I don't know. You just took a big swig of coffee and you're like, that's how it works in the business. Well, listen, you know what? David Wallace tells Michael he's just going to have to deal with it. Yeah. And he couldn't believe that one of his employees had been back so long and he didn't know.
而且她们会是年轻性感的侦探，穿着名牌服装。这行就是这么运作的。没错。我才没有愤世嫉俗呢。好吧，我们继续吧？我在纽约怎么了？我在这里是谁？我不知道。你刚刚大口喝了一口咖啡，然后你就像，这行就是这么运作的。好吧，听着，你知道吗？大卫·华尔士告诉迈克尔，他只能接受现实。是的。他简直不敢相信他的一个员工回来这么久了，他竟然不知道。
And Dwight and Michael let him know that the annex is icky. It's icky back there. Yeah. And he really wants David to get rid of Toby. And David says, I can't get rid of him without cause. And Michael says, he has cause. It's because I hate him. Because. But that is not obviously cause. Well, they're going to find something. But Jenna, another issue is happening. Yeah. It's a day of drama in the office. Pam is preparing food in the kitchen and she discovers a mess in the microwave. Jenna. Yeah. Did you see what Pam was preparing? I know what Pam was preparing. Share. This is maybe one of my most frequently asked questions outside of what was in the teapot note. No way. Yes. People are like, what is Pam microwaving in
德怀特和迈克尔让他知道办公区很恶心。后面很恶心。是的。而且他真的很想让大卫赶走托比。大卫说，我没有理由是不能赶走他的。迈克尔说，他有理由。因为我讨厌他。因为。但那显然不是正当理由。好吧，他们会找到借口的。不过珍娜，另一个问题正在发生。是的。这是办公室里充满戏剧性的一天。帕姆在厨房准备食物，她发现在微波炉里有一个烂摊子。珍娜。对。你看到帕姆在准备什么了吗？我知道帕姆在准备什么。分享一下。这可能是我被问得最多的问题之一，除了茶壶纸条里写的是什么。不会吧。真的。人们会问，在有脏微波炉那一集里，帕姆在微波炉里热的是什么？这里有一些猜测。我们收到了邮件。
the episode with the dirty microwave? Here are some guesses. We got mail. Here are what people are guessing that I was microwaving. Okay. Apple juice. A probiotic drink. Okay. Egg whites. Bone broth. Soup. Milk. Porridge. And yogurt. Well, I had no idea. So I looked at the script, but Jenna, you tell us. It's egg whites. It's egg whites, which I, by the way, knowing my BFF in real life thought was kind of fitting. Yeah. Because you can buy egg whites in these little cups. And that's what she's doing. She's going to microwave herself some egg whites. A lot of people also asked, what was in the microwave? That is also in the script. And it just says like a saucy mess, basically. I typed it out. It says, Pam opens the microwave door to
以下是人们猜测我当时在加热的东西。好的。苹果汁。益生菌饮料。好的。蛋清。骨头汤。汤。牛奶。粥。还有酸奶。好吧，我完全不知道。所以我看了剧本，但珍娜，你来告诉我们。是蛋清。是蛋清，顺便说一句，了解我现实生活中的死党后，我觉得这挺符合的。是的。因为你可以在这些小杯子里买到蛋清。这就是她正在做的。她要给自己微波炉热一些蛋清。很多人还问，微波炉里到底有什么？剧本里也写了。上面只写着类似酱汁般的烂摊子，基本上。我把它打出来了。上面写着，帕姆打开微波炉门
put in some egg whites, but the microwave is splattered all over with red sauce. Yeah. Now we're in the break room. And what would we title this? Jim's exposed in the break room. No, that doesn't sound good. Exposure in the break room. Exposure in the break room. Andy, I guess, has peepers like a hawk and read Jim's email and found out that Jim is buying his parents house and hasn't told Pam. Yeah. Or as Kevin puts it, the same house he used to pee the bed in. Phyllis thinks it's romantic. Until she asks Jim where it is, Jim says it's on Lyndon Ave. And Phyllis makes a face. And then in the background, you see me kind of roll my eyes like, ooh. I looked up Lyndon Ave in Scranton. I couldn't find a Lyndon Ave. I found a Lyndon Street,
把一些蛋清放进去，但微波炉到处都溅满了红酱。是的。现在我们在休息室。我们该给这个片段起个什么标题呢？吉姆在休息室曝光。不，听起来不太好。休息室里的曝光。休息室里的曝光。安迪，我猜他有着鹰一样的眼睛，读了吉姆的邮件，发现吉姆给他父母买了一栋房子，而且还没告诉帕姆。是的。或者正如凯文所说，就是他以前尿床的那栋房子。菲利斯觉得很浪漫。直到她问吉姆房子在哪里，吉姆说是朗登大道。菲利斯做了一个鬼脸。然后你在背景里可以看到我有点翻了个白眼，哦。我在斯克兰顿查了朗登大道。我没找到朗登大道。我找到了一条朗登街，
but it's sort of like in the heart of the city. There's like shops and churches and definitely no quarry nearby. Oh, interesting. We got a lot of questions from, for example, Brittany Y and Jenner B. Whose house did they use for Jim's parents house? Was the interior a set or was it the actual house that they used for the exterior? This is where Randy Cordray really came through for me, Ange. Bring it home, Randy. I remembered that it was two different houses. We used one for the interior and one for the exterior. And Randy said that our location manager, Kyle Alexander, had found several choices and that Randy had really hoped that they could find a single residence that they could do both interior and exterior, just because it would be so much easier
但它有点像在市中心。那里有商店、教堂，绝对没有什么采石场在附近。哦，有意思。我们收到了很多问题，例如来自布里塔尼·Y和珍娜·B的提问。他们用谁的房子来拍吉姆父母的房子？内景是布景还是他们外景实际使用的那栋房子？这就是兰迪·科德雷真正帮我解围的地方，安吉。说得好，兰迪。我记得那是两栋不同的房子。我们用了一栋作内景，另一栋作外景。兰迪说，我们的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大找了好几个选择，兰迪本来真的很希望他们能找到一个单独的住宅，既能拍内景也能拍外景，仅仅是因为只在一个地方拍摄会容易得多。但事情并没有那样发展。兰迪说他们看过的所有东西要么适合内景但
to shoot at just one location. But it didn't work out that way. Randy said everything they looked at either worked for the interior, but not the exterior or vice versa. So for the exterior, we used an occupied home on Calvert Street in Van Nuys, California. But the interior was not suitable to shoot. This was because it was absolutely adorable inside. And it needed to look a little janky. Yeah, it was so cute. And when we were shooting there, they would let John and I step in to the house to kind of get our makeup refreshed and touched up. But we would just stand right inside that front door. And then we would go back outside again. And that was it. And it was cute inside. Oh my God, it was so cute. It was decorated like, oh, like an English
不适合外景，反之亦然。所以对于外景，我们使用了加州范奈斯卡尔弗街上一栋有人住的房子。但内景不适合拍摄。这是因为里面实在是太可爱了。而它需要看起来稍微有点破旧。是的，里面太可爱了。当我们那儿拍摄时，他们会让我和约翰走进房子里去补妆和修饰。但我们只会站在那个前门里面。然后我们就会回到外面。就是这样。而且里面真的很可爱。哦天哪，太可爱了。里面的装饰就像，哦，就像一个英国教授的家，那种舒适温馨的文学风书架，里面是那种经过完美修复的漂亮房子，太棒了。我有一次在一个叫《反对者退散》的节目里做过类似的事情。我们在一个房子里拍外景，在另一个房子里拍内景。当我们拍外景时，天气很冷，还下着毛毛雨。他们让我们走进去，就进前厅。是的，一样。但我们就在那儿等着，对吧？是的。我们根本没有进到他们屋子里。但我们走进了前厅，我和史蒂夫·利特尔在一起，我们其实不知道会发生什么。我们打开门走进去。
professor's home, like just cozy, cozy literary bookshelves, just beautiful kind of restored home inside. So great. I did something similar one time on this show called Haters Back Off. We filmed the exterior in one house and the interior in another. And when we were filming the exterior, it was cold and kind of misty raining. And they let us step inside just the front room. Yeah, same. But we waited, right? Yeah. We didn't go throughout their house at all. But we stepped in the front room and I was with Steve Little and we weren't really sure what to expect. We opened the door to step in. And there was maybe 4,000 tiny dolls. What? Yes. What? There were dolls and cases, all kinds of fancy dolls in every kind of case you could imagine. Cases on the wall,
里面大概有 4000 个小娃娃。什么？是的。什么？到处都是娃娃和展示柜，各种你能想象到的精美娃娃，装在各种柜子里。墙上的柜子里，
little case stand on the ground. They were everywhere. And Steve and I stood right on the other side of the door and we're like, okay, so somebody likes dolls. Oh my gosh, I would be like run. Run now. It was like, okay, all right. If you have that many dolls, there's a very good chance that one of them is going to come alive and try to kill you. I mean, if we've learned anything, one of them is possessed. One of them is possessed. And you know who's on the case? The mom detectives. The mom detectives. We got that covered. We got it covered. We'll hide in the bushes. We'll figure it out. That's right. So this house was so cute. What Michael Gallenberg did, our set designer, he added a broken rain gutter to the outside. He changed the front door
地上的小展示架上。到处都是。我和史蒂夫直接站在门的那一边，心里想，好吧，看来有人很喜欢娃娃。哦天哪，我会想逃跑。现在就跑。当时的感觉就是，好吧，好吧。如果你有那么多娃娃，很有可能其中有一个会活过来并试图杀死你。我的意思是，如果我们学到了什么，那就是其中有一个被附身了。其中有一个被附身了。你知道谁在调查这个案吗？妈妈侦探。妈妈侦探。我们搞定这个了。我们搞定它了。我们会藏在灌木丛里。我们会弄清楚的。没错。所以这栋房子太可爱了。迈克尔·加伦堡，我们的布景设计师，在外面加了一个坏掉的雨水槽。他改了前门
so that it would match the other location. Okay. Where we go inside. And he also added that swinging screen door that bangs into the overhead awning. Oh, that was really funny. I know. And then they also asked the homeowner to turn off their sprinklers for a week leading up to the shoot to make the grass look kind of dry and weather beaten. And they did. They kind of killed their lawn for us. Thank you. Now for the interior of Jim's parents house and for the garage scenes, they found an unoccupied home on Allatt Avenue, which is also in Van Nuys. It was only a few blocks away from the other house. And for this one, they went in, they added the shag carpeting, they added the wood paneling. They changed the front door. Like they bought a front door and they put it on both
好让它和另一个外景地匹配。好的。也就是我们进去的那个地方。他还加了那扇会撞到头顶遮阳篷的弹簧纱门。哦，那真的太搞笑了。我知道。然后他们还让屋主在拍摄前的一周关掉洒水系统，好让草地看起来有点干枯饱经风霜。他们真的照做了。他们为了我们把草坪差不多弄死了。谢谢。至于吉姆父母家的内景和车库的场景，他们在阿勒特大道上找到了一栋没有住人的房子，这条街也在范奈斯。它离另一栋房子只有几个街区远。对于这个，他们走进去，铺上了长毛地毯，加上了木质护墙板。他们换了前门——就像他们买了一扇前门，把它安在两栋
houses so it would match, you know. So he was able to go in and completely set design the interior of the home. Is it a LLOT? A LLOTT. And you say it a lot or allot? Allot. Allot? Allot. So from everything I said, the thing that we're going to discuss is the street name and how to pronounce it. I want you to know something. Whenever I think about like where I'm going to live, I think about the name of the street and having to tell it to like the pizza delivery guy. I live on allot. Allot. A-L-L-O-T. No, not allot. Not allot. Allot. I play it out in my head. You guys don't do that? Clearly, you'd rather live on Calvert Street. Calvert. Yes. Much easier for you to get your pizza on Calvert. That's right. I'm not spelling that every single time.
房子上，这样就能匹配，你知道的。所以他能够进去，把房屋的内景完全设计好。是 A-L-L-O-T 吗？A-L-L-O-T。你是读“阿洛特”还是“阿洛特”？阿洛特。阿洛特？阿洛特。所以在我说过的话里，我们要讨论的事情竟然是街道名称以及怎么发音。我想让你们知道一件事。每当我想象我要住在哪里时，我都会想到街道的名字，以及不得不把名字告诉送披萨的小哥时的情景。我住在阿洛特。阿洛特。A-L-L-O-T。不，不是阿洛特。不是阿洛特。阿洛特。我在脑海里排练过这个。你们不那样做吗？显然，你宁愿住在卡尔弗街。卡尔弗。是的。你在卡尔弗更容易买到披萨。没错。我才不会每次都拼写那个呢。
This is like how strongly I felt about pockets in women's clothing. This is your soapbox moment, Angela. Yeah. I can't tell you like how many times I've had to spell my street name out. It's annoying. I'm not going to say it. Don't need the creepers. You don't want anyone in your bush? I don't want anyone. Well, I might want someone in my bush, but I- I think he already lives with you. Oh, jeez, Louise. Oh my gosh. I don't know what's happening to us today. Should I go to New York more or less? I don't know. I don't know. Oh my lord. We had some more questions because Jim, during this talking head, he's showing us his parents' house. And Sam Kay would like to know,
这就像我对女性服装口袋的强烈执念一样。这是你的长篇大论时刻，安吉拉。是的。我简直说不清我有多少次不得不把我的街道名字拼写出来。太烦人了。我才不说呢。不需要变态跟踪狂。你不想让任何人进你的灌木丛？我不想让任何人。不过，我可能想让某人在我的灌木丛里，但我——我觉得他已经和你住在一起了。哦，天哪，路易丝。哦天哪。我不知道我们今天怎么了。我是应该多去纽约还是少去？我不知道。我不知道。哦，天哪。我们还有更多问题，因为吉姆在这次单人访谈中，他给我们展示他父母的房子。山姆·K想知道，
please explain the clown picture in Jim's parents' house. Please explain. Yeah. In the script, it just says, Jim examines a hideous painting of some clowns putting out a fire. He tries to pull it off with all his might. Nothing. Jim grimaces. Randy Cordray told me that that clown painting was provided. It was made original for us by one of Phil Shea's go-to artists. He did not have the artist's name in his files, so we'd like to put it out there. If you are listening and you are the person who painted the clown painting, will you contact us on Office Ladies Pod? We want to know more. But Randy Cordray said that the artist actually provided them with multiple preliminary choices. And that Mindy, Greg, Paul, and Jen all had to stand and look at
请解释一下吉姆父母家里的那幅小丑画。请解释一下。是的。在剧本里，只写着，吉姆端详着一幅丑陋的画，画上是一些小丑在灭火。他使出吃奶的力气试图把它从墙上拽下来。纹丝不动。吉姆做了一个痛苦的表情。兰迪·科德雷告诉我，那幅小丑画是特制的。那是菲尔·谢伊手下的一个御用艺术家专门为我们原创制作的。他的档案里没有那个艺术家的名字，所以我们想把它说出来。如果你正在收听，而你就是画那幅小丑画的人，请在“办公室女士”播客联系我们。我们想了解更多。但兰迪·科德雷说，艺术家实际上为他们提供了多个初步选择。而且明蒂、格雷格、保罗和珍都在那里站着看
multiple clown paintings. And that's the one they chose. That was their job that day. Yeah. Pick the clown painting. That was your day. I had to pick a clown painting. So crazy. It cracked me up that it was on the wall like that and that he couldn't remove it because I feel like that's such a dad move. You know, it's like that moment where your mom is like, that painting is always tilted. It's always tilted. And then your dad goes and super glues it to the wall because he's tired of it tilting. It just made me laugh. I want to know the story behind why they bolted it down. Yeah. What is the story there? There's a story. We don't know what it is exactly. We don't know. Well, now guess what? Oscar and Andy discover a note on the microwave.
多幅小丑画。这就是他们选的那幅。那成了他们当天的任务。是的。选一幅小丑画。这就是你们的一天。我得挑一幅小丑画。太疯狂了。它挂在墙上那个样子，而且他没办法把它拿下来，这让我觉得太搞笑了，因为我觉得这真是一个爸爸才会做的事。你知道，就像那一刻，你妈妈说，那幅画一直是倾斜的。它总是倾斜的。然后你爸就走过去把它用强力胶粘在墙上，因为他受够了它总是斜着。这真的让我笑出声来。我想知道他们为什么把它用螺栓固定在墙上的故事。是的。那背后的故事是什么？这里面有个故事。我们不知道具体是什么。我们不知道。好吧，现在你猜怎么着？奥斯卡和安迪在微波炉上发现了一张字条。
It's a very shaming note. It is. They think that the note is worse than the mess. Angela likes the note. She does. Meredith thinks that the person who wrote the note is definitely rich and should get off their high horse. I love this moment with this note on the microwave. I do too. It's so relatable. If you have ever worked in an office, there is at least once in your time of working in that office, a note stuck to something about something that people are like, eh. Yeah. And also the note where the person leaving the note has clearly reached their limit. Yeah. Yeah. They can't take it anymore. No, the note is masking a deep river of anger. They're just pissed. Well, I think this is such
这是一张充满羞辱意味的字条。确实。他们觉得这张字条比那个烂摊子还要恶劣。安吉拉很喜欢这张字条。她确实喜欢。梅雷迪思觉得写这张字条的人绝对是个有钱人，应该别那么自以为是。我很喜欢这个微波炉字条的时刻。我也是。太有共鸣了。如果你在办公室工作过，在你工作的期间，至少会有那么一次，有一张字条贴在某样东西上，是关于某件事的，大家会觉得，呃。是的。而且，留下字条的人也显然已经忍无可忍了。是的。是的。他们受够了。不，这张字条掩盖了内心的滔滔怒火。他们只是被气疯了。好吧，我觉得这是一个非常有趣的时刻，
a fun moment because we get to see Pam and Angela in agreement about something. I think Pam starts to doubt her note a little bit when she realizes that Angela is on her side. Do you think? Yeah, I do. Well, the cool thing is that this moment at the microwave would have continued in the script. There are two talking heads here, one from Pam and one from Angela. And lady, I thought we could read them. I did too. And they really further the story. It's so fun. Okay. Here was Pam's talking head from the script. She's holding up the note. This is the front of the note. And then it says Pam holds up a memo. This is the front of my latest office memorandum. This can only lead anyone to believe that I wrote the note, which I did.
因为我们看到帕姆和安吉拉在某件事上达成了一致。我觉得当帕姆意识到安吉拉站在她这边时，她开始对自己的字条产生了一点怀疑。你觉得呢？是的，我确实这么觉得。好吧，酷的是，微波炉前的这一幕在剧本里本该继续下去。这里有两个单人访谈，一个是帕姆的，一个是安吉拉的。女士，我想我们可以把它们读出来。我也这么想。它们确实推动了剧情发展。太有趣了。好的。这是剧本里帕姆的单人访谈。她举着字条。这是字条正面。然后写着：帕姆举起一份备忘录。这是我最新的办公室备忘录的正面。这只能让任何人相信是我写了这张字条，确实是我写的。
And then immediately it would cut to Angela's talking head. And this was what was in the script. Everyone keeps asking if I wrote the note on the microwave. It was so perfectly worded and a little bit snotty. I wish I had written it. Now, there were even more candy bag talking heads, which we'd filmed as well. And they ended up in deleted scenes. But these are the two that were in the script. Yes. And you guys, what cracks me up as well? I don't know if you noticed this. Not only are Pam and Angela kind of oddly on the same side of this argument, did you notice, Jenna, that they're dressed alike? Yes. I noticed that Pam is doing that thing that Angela always does where she wears like a weird short sleeve sweater over a blouse.
And then immediately it would cut to Angela's talking head. And this was what was in the script. Everyone keeps asking if I wrote the note on the microwave. It was so perfectly worded and a little bit snotty. I wish I had written it. Now, there were even more candy bag talking heads, which we'd filmed as well. And they ended up in deleted scenes. But these are the two that were in the script. Yes. And you guys, what cracks me up as well? I don't know if you noticed this. Not only are Pam and Angela kind of oddly on the same side of this argument, did you notice, Jenna, that they're dressed alike? Yes. I noticed that Pam is doing that thing that Angela always does where she wears like a weird short sleeve sweater over a blouse.|||然后镜头马上切到安吉拉的单人访谈。这就是剧本里的内容。每个人都在问我是不是在微波炉上留了便条。这字句太完美了，还有点刻薄。我真希望是我写的。当时，还有更多的糖果袋单人访谈，我们也拍了。它们最后成了被删减的片段。但这两个是剧本里有的。对。还有你们大家，让我觉得很好笑的是什么？我不知道你们有没有注意到这一点。不仅帕姆和安吉拉在这个争论中有些奇怪地站在了同一边，珍娜，你有没有注意到她们穿得一样？是的。我注意到帕姆在模仿安吉拉总是做的那种举动，就是在一件衬衫外面套一件奇怪的短袖毛衣。
They both have v-neck short sleeve sweaters over short sleeve blouses. Angela's is like brown on brown and Pam's is black over purple. But what is this short sleeve sweater? I have to believe that was a genius wardrobe choice by Alicia Raycraft. I think so. Because that is funny. I screen grabbed them. I'm going to put them on side by side in stories. Well, we got a fan question from Maddie and Laura. They asked, in the episode, both Pam and Angela agree that the note on the microwave was acceptable and correct. Where do you guys stand in real life as Jenna and Angela note or no note? You go. You go first. You go. Why are you making me go first? Oh, I'll tell you what. I'm probably
They both have v-她们两个都穿着v领短袖毛衣，里面是短袖衬衫。安吉拉的是棕色配棕色，帕姆的是黑色套紫色。但这种短袖毛衣是怎么回事？我不得不相信这是艾莉西亚·雷克拉夫（Alicia Raycraft）天才般的服装选择。我也这么觉得。因为这太搞笑了。我截图了。我打算把它们并排放到快拍里。好吧，我们收到了来自玛迪和劳拉的一个粉丝提问。他们问，在这一集中，帕姆和安吉拉都认为微波炉上的便条是可以接受的而且是正确的。作为珍娜和安吉拉，你们在现实生活中持什么立场，留便条还是不留便条？你来。你先来。你来。为什么非要让我先来？哦，我跟你说。我可能
a no note. I'll just sort of like stew and resent you forever. I'm probably a no note. But here is my reaction to the note. When I see the note, I'm like, you know what? You needed that. Whoever you are out in the world, you needed to get it out. So I'm okay with it. One time, Jenna, I'll never forget this. I was in high school and I had finally gotten my driver's license and we went to the mall. You know, you're going to go to the mall. And I think, Jenna, because I was so excited. I had my friends in the car with me. We're at the mall. I was a little distracted and maybe I didn't do the best parking job. Okay. And after our day of going to Claire's boutique and hitting up 579, maybe the candle store, we go back out to my car and there is a note.
是一个不留便条的人。我只会有点生闷气，然后永远恨你。我可能是不留便条的人。但这是我对这张便条的反应。当我看到这张便条时，我想，你知道吗？你需要这个。不管你是世上的哪个人，你需要把它宣泄出来。所以我能接受。有一次，珍娜，我永远不会忘记这件事。我上高中时，终于拿到了驾照，我们去了商场。你知道的，你总会去商场。我想，珍娜，因为我太兴奋了。我的朋友们和我坐在车里。我们在商场。我有点分心，可能没有把车停好。好吧。在我们去克莱尔精品店（Claire's boutique）、逛了579号店，可能还有蜡烛店的一天结束后，我们回到我的车旁，上面有一张便条。
I'm so sorry. You bought candles as a teenager? It goes that far back for you? I love the candle. And the candle. Teenage Angela went to the mall and she went to the candle store. She loved Yankee Candles, Jenna. Okay. I'm so sorry. Go on. You get to your car. Yankee Candles. It was right next to the Hallmark store. I could get myself a card, maybe a knickknack. Go get a candle. I'm sorry. How old are you? You're 16 in this story. I've been a grandma my whole life. Anyway, I walk back out to my car with my friends. This is my first outing in my car to the mall. Yeah. There's a note under my windshield wiper. What's it say? This is what it said. Hey dickhead. Next time leave me a can opener so I can get into
my car. Sorry. I was like, what? I must have sandwiched the guy's car. I don't know. Oh, but you know what? I was like, he needed that. Whoever he or she was, they needed this. They needed to get it out. Okay. So basically where you stand on notes is you wouldn't write one yourself, but you don't have a big kind of reaction. You don't take them personally when they're out. You sort of like that person needed to get it out. Think about the time it takes to sit down and write a note or type it out and print it on a piece of colored paper like Pam did. She had two different colors. She had black ink. She had red ink. It was on a yellow piece of paper. She clearly needed to be heard in this moment. Yeah. So I would just hear her.
Would you clean the microwave if it was dirty? I probably would. Wow. I would probably just clean it because I mean who needs and then that's done. Wow. I would just clean it. If I go into the little kitchen here at Ear Wolf and there's like a mess around the sink and it's not my mess, I just wipe it up. Here's what I would do. Okay. You look very serious. That's why I'm like, okay. While I'm thinking about it in my head, I'm really trying to, you know, ask myself, who am I? What would I do? I'm a problem solver, right? So if I kept going in the kitchen and there kept being a dirty microwave and there was no system in place for who cleans it, I would want to create that system or create that rule. 100%, Jenna, you would make a chore wheel. Yes. And we would all, like,
on Mondays, I would be in charge of cleaning the office sink. Yes. Or it's Monday Microwave Day. We'd give it a fun name and that's the cleaning day and it would rotate around and, you know, part of that would be the cleaner you keep the microwave, the less work on the day you have to clean it. So it'll incentivize us all to keep a cleaner microwave because no one's going to want to clean it on their clean day. I like that very much about you. You're solution based. I am. Well, in the script, the microwave storyline continues. There is now another note on top of Pam's original note and it says this, hey, anonymous coward who left the note, be a man, spend less time writing notes and more time cleaning up the microwave. Yeah. And then,
it continues. Throughout the episode, there would have been more notes piling up on the microwave, not just on the microwave, they're on the cabinets. They ran out of space on the microwave, they're taping them to the cabinets around the microwave. There are so many notes that clearly people have written multiple notes because there's not even that many people in the office to weigh in on this, right? So here's one of the notes. Hey, whoever was bashing the first note, grow up, the microwave is filthy and no one here is a maid. And then there's another one that says, you are all a bunch of idiots and privileged ass wipes who weren't raised right. If I find you, I'm going to knock your teeth out. That's got to be Meredith, right? Do you think it's Creed?
I think it's Meredith. I mean, Meredith is the obvious choice, but I think we could find out that Creed wrote it. Lady, I think we should take a break because when we come back, Michael is about to serve up some high caliber acting. I mean, watch out, Kurt Russell. Yeah, Michael Scott's coming for you. He sure is. All right, we'll be right back. It's time for Michael to do his best. This is Michael's best. Michael approaches Toby's desk to welcome him back. He's asking questions about Costa Rica. Toby says it was amazing, but he came back because it was kind of hard to meet people. It was hot, but Michael can't stand it. He cannot stand this incredibly innocent small talk with
Toby. No, he can't. He goes back to his office. He has this talking head where he's like, I tried, I tried, I tried to talk to Toby and be his friend, but it's like trying to be friends with an evil snail. I want to know who in the writer's room came up with evil snail because it's so funny. It's such a good description of Toby. Such a good description. And then he goes on to say, he feels like Nev Campbell in Scream 2. And he has this very funny talking head where he learned a lot, I guess, from the Scream movies. But Jenna, there was another talking head in the script. So the one you see with the Nev Campbell, that was not in the script. So that must have been an alternate talking head they handed him on the day. In the script, this is Michael's talking head.
It's almost the same right up until the evil snail. So evil snail was in the script? Yes, evil snail was a keeper. We've always had that. But this is how it changed in the script. The last four months without Toby have been absolute bliss. I fell in love with a beautiful blonde woman. I fell out of love. I tried scallops. The office was broken into. I became a father. I grew a goatee. The Olympics were a great success for China. And now that I've tasted freedom, I can never go back. I'm going to kill him. No, too far. But I will do something. No, too little. I will get rid of him. Oh, I like it. I love his breakdown of what all happened. And I love that he included he grew a goatee. Me too. It's true, in fact, that Michael is going
to try to get rid of Toby. He is looking for fireable offenses. Dwight says there are two that he can find in this binder, workplace violence or sexual harassment. So I guess Michael's first plan is to try to get Toby to sexually harass Pam. He goes up to Pam's desk, he hands Pam a note, and he says, go give this note to Toby. Don't read it. Don't read it. Pam reads it. In the note, it's written as if it's from Pam. And it says, please hug and kiss me no matter how much I struggle. I'm too shy to confess my love to you. Can you imagine if Toby had read that note? His brain would have exploded. Yeah. Well, that doesn't work. Yeah. Pam's like, no, I'm not going back there. So now the new plan is to get Toby to beat up Michael. Yeah. So they march back
to the annex and Michael's sort of confronting Toby and trying to sort of, you know, antagonize him to hit him. And Dwight's like, hit him. And then Kelly jumps in so quickly, hit him. I know. First of all, her and Ryan were making out. Oh yeah. That they've stopped making out so that they can weigh in and therefore fight. They're like, do it. Hit him. Hit him. Toby refuses. It's not working. None of these plans are working. So you know what they're going to have to do? They're going to have to go big. They're going to have to frame Toby for drugs, like on the shield. I love that Dwight said I've framed many animals. I framed a raccoon opening a Christmas gift. Well, Michael thinks it sounds mean, but sometimes the end justifies the mean. That's such a good line. It's such a good line.
It's so smart. It's smart money. It reminds me of this gem. I'm not superstitious, but I'm a little bit stitious. Yes, that it's right in line with that. So yeah, Michael's going to go and hit up Leo and Gino over in Vance Refrigeration for some drugs. They give him what they say is two pounds of weed and they want $500. Michael has $500 in his wallet. I thought the same thing. That's a lot of cash in your wallet. And for my background catch people, did you see the Lackawanna library card? In Michael's wallet? Yes, when he opens his wallet, there's a Lackawanna county library card. Do you know what I found recently when I was cleaning out my closet? What? Pam's wallet. You did. And in it, there's a credit card that says Pam Beasley.
There's all these cards they made for my wallet, my prop wallet. I'll take a picture, we'll put it in pod. Yeah, we have to put it in stories. That's so fun. How crazy is that? They did that. That's how detailed Phil Shea was. If you had a prop wallet, it reflected your character. Although, is Michael going to the library and why? What's that for? I mean, I feel like Michael's probably had that library card for like 20 years in his wallet. Yeah. Maybe there was a time where he didn't have internet and he'd have to go to the library. Oh wait, we didn't have internet. I know. Maybe he used to go to the library to make copies because the copier in the office is crap. We'll get to that next week.
Yeah. So, Anne, you know how when sometimes we're watching an episode or we're breaking down our document to prep to do the podcast, we'll get curious about something and we'll do a deep dive? Did you do one on something? I didn't. Our associate producer Ainsley. Ainsley, what'd you deep dive? This is what she wrote me. She said, according to a regrettable Google search, the price of one pound of recreational marijuana in Pennsylvania ranges from $1,900 to $2,550. She had to know. She was like, okay, they're selling Michael two pounds of weed for $500. Ainsley got curious, how much is a pound of weed in Pennsylvania? And now I looked and we shot this in September of 2008. So how much was it in 2008?
I'm not sure, but today that's going to run you quite a bit of money. With today's prices, Michael got a deal because it would cost him close to $5,000 to get two pounds of weed today. I also want to say that's clearly not two pounds of anything in that baggie. No, it's green, but it's not two pounds. I mean, two pounds. I have two pounds of things all over my house, like two pound weights, two pound bag of flour. That's not two pounds of anything. It's not. I've had a two pound bag of spinach in my house before. It's much bigger than that. It takes up the whole crisper drawer. You're very passionate about painting a very clear picture of what two pounds is. I mean, it's so glaringly obvious that that's not two pounds.
There are so many signs that Michael is missing. Don't get Jenna started. Don't get me started on what two pounds of something is. I'll tell you about my two pounds of spinach. I just ordered two pounds of Epsom salts and that was a large package as well. What are you making? Warm soothing bath. Well, listen, we're about to find out that Pam has an ally in this whole microwave business. Does she? She has Ryan who's pretending to be an ally and he's laying it on thick and I love it. Yeah, he says I'm totally on your side. But the truth is he went to make a cup of noodles and the microwave is still a mess and he wants her to clean it up and she delivers some real Pam sass. Hey Pam, I just want to let you know I'm totally on your side with the whole microwave situation.
Thank you. I was just back there to make some cup of soup. The thing is still a huge mess. I know. Can you believe it? Yeah, it's crazy. But I guess the thing is at some point, notes are no notes. Someone's going to have to just get in there and clean it up. I guess that's why we have a temp, huh? Oh no, trust me. I would just make it worse. How would wiping it with a paper towel make it worse? I would find a way. You've seen things clean before though, right? I am hopeless at that stuff. I mean, that's some good Pam sass. That was all scripted. I know it sounds like Jenna sass. It was scripted. I just brought myself to it. You brought some real truth to it.
I did. Well, Ange, we got a lot of fan questions asking who did clean the microwave? Because this never gets wrapped up. We never find out. Did it get clean? Who cleaned it? This would have wrapped up. It's in the script and we filmed a big scene that would have explained all of it. It was a fun scene too. It was and it has a great Pam Angela moment at the top. Yeah. So it starts with Angela. She's storming in from the kitchen. She's super ticked off and she's holding up a note. Someone has drawn a penis on the note and she confronts Pam. I know. She thinks Pam drew the penis. Why does she always blame Pam for this kind of stuff? I don't know. Here's how it went.
Pervert. Ange, well, I didn't do that. So is this what they taught you at your fancy art school? Why would I draw a penis on my own note? Why do you wear bright colors for attention, Pam? Everyone, I have an announcement to make. I'm the person who put the first note on the microwave. Yeah. Pam comes clean. And I remember shooting this because Pam kind of goes on to take charge of the room after she admits that she wrote the note. She's like, and I guess I just have to say what's so wrong about the note? Why is everyone so offended by this note? Shouldn't you be more offended by a consistently dirty microwave? She gets on her soapbox. It's Pam's soapbox. It's Pam's soapbox. And you guys, as an actor, when we got to have a moment where we commanded the
whole bullpen, it was exciting. And also we were kind of terrified. Oh yeah. Because you're in charge of the pace of the scene. This only happened to me a handful of times when Angela makes a big announcement or something. But I remember Jenna watching you and you were so good in this moment because everyone is throwing you little curveballs, Oscar and Stanley and Kevin. They're all kind of sassing you. And you know, the last time that I had a scene like this was back in beach games when Pam is going to confront the whole group about her feelings and how they didn't come to her art show. But in this instance, people were interrupting me and they're coming at me. And I got such a window into what Steve's every day was. Yeah. At one point, the group starts
hazing Pam about being in New York. And Pam gives this speech that kind of takes Jim off guard. And I think we should hear it. Listen, New York. That might fly. Why? Because I went to New York for three months. That and the black sweater, Manhattan. Okay, yes. I went to New York, everybody. I'm not going to apologize for it. I experienced more there in one week than I experienced here in three months. I love New York. You know, I especially love that people there cleaned up after themselves. Well, Jim has just heard her say all that. Yeah. And the camera is pushing in on his face and he's realizing at the end of today, he's going to tell her he bought them a house in Scranton. She's not going back to New York anytime soon. This place she loves. I really wish this
moment had made it into the show because I feel like it just sets up the stakes for Jim because he's doubting his decision from the very beginning. Did I do the right thing? Is she going to like this? I don't know. And I feel like he needed to hear this and I feel like the audience needed to hear it. I do too. I think it's a shame that it got cut out. And you know, at the end of this whole scene, Pam says, fine, I'll go clean it. So it is Pam in the end who cleaned the microwave. Yes, in the script, the very last line of this big scene says this, Pam marches over to the kitchen and Stanley starts to slow clap. Oh yeah. We had a slow clap that didn't make it. Oh yeah, that's right. Oh, that's bringing back that memory of me walking to Stanley's slow clap.
So good. It's time for Michael to plant what he thinks is two pounds of marijuana in Toby's desk. And at the same time, Dwight is going to call the police and report that there is a drug dealer named Toby Flandersen on the premises. And when asked to give his name, Dwight says his name is Andy Bernard. Dwight is going to throw Andy under the bus any chance he gets. There was this deleted scene, Jenna, that for Michael to be able to have the time to go plant the drugs, they needed to get Toby away from his desk. So Dwight asked Toby to show him his photos from Costa Rica. Let's go to the conference room. I'll look at your photos. Toby is thrilled that someone wants to see his photos. And then Michael sneaks off to plant
the drugs. But in true Michael fashion, he can't keep this secret. He has to share with someone that he might have just done something. This is what he said. I think it's really cool that you wanted to see my photos. What's this for? Pink thing on that white oval. That's me. I was boogie boarding. Who took this picture? Did you make some friends? I hired a local kid to snap it. Tell me about this monkey. I am not at liberty to talk about it. Let's just say that I somethinged something in somebody's something. And if discovered, then someone will get something. I may have said too much. He can't not say anything. He can't. Containment is not his strong suit.
No. And then I have to say that scene with Dwight and Toby, to me, it sounded like Rainn Wilson improvising questions, trying to stump Paul Lieberstein. Jenna, you're not wrong. I'm looking at the script right now. The part with what's the red thing crawling on that oval, that was scripted. Okay. But the tell me about this monkey is not in the script. Okay. Also, what about that question? Who took these pictures? That's in the script. Oh, it is. Yes. That's a funny line. The improv moment is the monkey. Okay. Now the police arrive and they are going to look into this possible narcotics situation. Pam doesn't know anything about it. Dwight's going to take charge. And then Michael starts freaking out. Yes. And then they
realize it's a Ziploc of maybe like what, a Caprese salad? Yeah, it looks like there's definitely some cheese in there and some salad dressing. Yeah. I'll have you know, the police officers were played by Patrick Fossett and Michael Heridy, and neither of them have been on monk, I checked. Oh, good call to check though. Also, can we talk about how when the police first arrived, Creed stood up as if he was going to be handcuffed and then put his hands behind his head. Yeah. And then he's talking head where he's like, just keep talking to me until the police leave. I love it. So good. I love it so much. We got some fan mail. Brooke El said that Toby seemed very concerned about police officers searching his desk. Could this be because they might find
evidence of him being the Scranton Strangler? Oh, I don't know. At 16 minutes, 27 seconds, we have a very rare side by side talking head. So rare. How did they get through it? I don't know. Michael and Toby side by side. I know. I would have loved to have been a fly on a wall in that talking head because you know, I looked for the bloopers. I was like, surely, surely there's something on the blooper reel. I looked too. Yes. Because I was like, I know these guys. I know Steve and Paul together and they were as tickled by the Toby-Michael relationship as the audience was as we all were. Yes. And they would mess with each other. You remember in a scene, there's a blooper where Toby has to hand Michael a piece of paper and Steve and him start cracking
up because Paul wrote you on it. Yes. So I know they were giving it to each other and I wish there were some bloopers from this. There is footage somewhere for sure. Somewhere. Well, listen, in the annex, Ryan and Kelly are making out again. Oh, it's such a sloppy make out too. It is. Not that a tidy make out would have made it any better at work. Exactly. Well, Ryan wants out. He doesn't want a sloppy make out. He doesn't want a tidy one. He's going to Thailand with some friends from high school, a high school. You know, he has to break up with her because if he doesn't, he'll always resent her. If he didn't go, he would like them to be adults about it. Maybe they could have sex one more time. And does she have any cash? Then let's be adults
about it, but we could also have sex one more time. I've got such a dude move. I feel like I've heard that so many times. I know. Do you want to have some goodbye sex? No. No, just goodbye. Get your sorry ass out of here. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Fan question from Gracie are, when Ryan is telling Kelly he's going to Thailand, why are they both wearing different clothes? I'll tell you, Gracie, because this scene was originally supposed to be the tag at the end of the episode, and it was meant to be a new workday. So in the script, this scene was not during the same day that we were framing Toby. It was the next day. But in editing, they moved it up, and we are going to end instead with a delicious Dwight talking head. We'll get to it. But first,
Jim needs to show Pam what he's done. That's right. Jim is nervous, but excited. He is, as my daughter says, nervous-sided. And she's like, why are we stopping at your parents' house? And he says, I bought it. And then, Jenna, at 18 minutes, two seconds, Jim says, let's go inside. I'll show you inside. What? Has Pam never been inside the house? We got so much mail about that. People wrote in. They said if Pam knew they were at Jim's parents' house when they pulled up, wouldn't that mean she's been there before and she's probably been inside? You would hope Pam has been inside his parents' house. They've been dating for a while. They live in the same town. Yeah. And it's interesting because his parents have moved out, but they've
left some furniture. Also, how rough were they on this house? I know. And Jim says, I was helping my mom out. Where's his dad? I don't know. I have a lot of questions. There were a lot of questions. Rachel M. and Megan L. said, question for Jenna. In this episode, when Jim is showing Pam his parents' house, I was wondering what went into how you decided to play this scene because she seems really worried and unexcited. But then in the end, she says she loves it. Any input you could give about how you decided to play this or what the director told you would be super appreciated. Well, guys, we've already discussed my personal opinions on someone buying someone else a house without telling them. So this was a little bit of a mental gymnastics for me.
To get Pam to the place where she's going to say she loves it and where she says that line, I mean, you bought me a house because it was like not how I would react as Jenna. I had to really play the character and play the character's truth. And in the script, I was being told that my character's truth was that she loved this gesture and it made her feel loved. Yeah. Well, I mean, I think we often did that. Obviously, we had to play the truth for the character. I mean, I hope you guys know, I'm not very much like Angela Martin and how I would react to things, but it made sense to me, Jenna for Pam, you know, and Jim made the garage into this art studio. And he's really putting down some roots with her. And I think Pam wanted a family and she
wanted all of these things that Jim is offering her. She had wanted that. Yeah, you know, I had thought a little bit back on the talking head where Pam discusses what her perfect home would look like, how she always wanted a home with a terrace. You know, picking her home seemed like something that Pam was attached to. So I did bring that up. I said, you know, we've established that Pam has daydreamed about what her home would look like. And now this person has taken her out of the process. You brought that up to the writers at the time of when we were filming? Yeah. And so I was saying like, help me understand why Pam now is so happy and so excited. And Angela, we got to exactly what you just said, which was that it was a vulnerable thing for Pam to give
up the art school track. And she did that because of two reasons. One, graphic design wasn't what she meant she wanted to do as an artist. And two, she's ready. She's very, very ready to start living this married life to be in the season of family and marriage with this man that she's been waiting years for. And so this home is her fast track to that season of her life. And she's just ready. Yeah. And you know, they're going to get to fix it up together. So there's still that element of nesting that's going to get to happen. And so that's kind of what I was thinking was like, I'm ready. Yeah. And you have to think when Pam talked about her dream house with this tower and the terrace and all of that, she was in an unhappy relationship. When you're in a place
you feel stuck in life or you're unhappy, you daydream. And you daydream about these fantastical things. And they're coping mechanisms. And then when you're with someone you really love, you don't need the fantasy anymore. That's such a good point, Angela. You're just ready to have a life. And she's ready to have that life. Yeah. Now we did get some mail about that garage. Katie C and Chris G said, when Jim is showing Pam his parents' house, he says the garage has great lighting. He then proceeds to open a windowless garage door revealing a completely windowless garage space. Where's the great lighting, Jim? Where? Okay, well, I thought that was really funny. That is really funny. I want you guys to know that I have a garage that we use as a home office.
And for a long time, we would just raise the door. And then there would be amazing light, you know? Yeah. So it did get great light, but you had to raise the door. And then years later, we actually just removed the door because we're like, this is never going to be a garage again. You know, we've sort of made it into this little home office and put an actual sliding glass door. But I get it. It does have great lighting. You just have to open it up. But he does present it like this garage has great lighting. As if the other garages that you open the whole side of the building wouldn't have great lighting. He's presenting as if it's like a special feature. Yeah. That kind of applies to every garage that doesn't have like a giant tree planted in front
of it, which it wouldn't because it's a garage. Right. Most garages are just boxes with no windows. I have to tell you two things about shooting these scenes at the house. The scene where Jim is trying to take the clown painting off the wall for Pam is one of the hardest I've ever laughed on the show. It is the second hardest time. The first was when we did the scene in dinner party where Michael's showing us the tiny TV on the wall. This is the second. Every time John tried to lift the painting on the wall, I could not stop laughing. I don't know what it was. Tears, tears choking on our laughter. We laughed so hard. I looked for it in the bloopers and it's not there. And I'm so upset it's not there. It took us like an hour to shoot that tiny
moment of him trying to take the painting off the wall. John is also so funny at physical comedy. Yes. I laughed out loud when he peeled back that fake wood paneling and it kind of startled him. Yes. So then at the end of the scene in the garage, when we're hugging, I improvised the line, what about the clown? And it made John laugh. And that's why he's like burying his head into my neck. And then when he said, yeah, I can't do anything about that, it made me laugh. And so I'm like smushing my face into his shoulder. You can totally tell we're breaking. And that's why it was because we were still, anytime we brought up the clown painting, we lost it. I love that moment. It made it intimate and funny and sweet. I think it's time to talk about the greatest white talking
他试图把画从墙上取下来的那一幕。约翰的肢体幽默也太搞笑了。是的。当他掀开那个假木板墙饰吓了他一跳时，我真的笑出了声。是的。所以在车库场景的最后，当我们拥抱时，我即兴发挥了一句台词，小丑怎么办？这把约翰逗笑了。这就是为什么他把头埋在我的脖子里的原因。然后当他说，是的，我对此无能为力时，这把我逗笑了。所以我就把脸埋进他的肩膀里。你完全看得出来我们在笑场。原因就是我们仍然，每次提到小丑画像时，我们就破功了。我太喜欢那个时刻了。它让那一幕既亲密、搞笑又甜蜜。我觉得是时候谈谈史上最棒的受访镜头了
head of all time. That's saying a lot because there are some amazing white talking heads, but this one really is like top five. He's going to describe his perfect crime. And I think we have to hear it. Every time I watched this episode, I laughed at that line and I watched it like three times. This entire talking head was scripted and it was delivered as scripted. I think this is one of the most brilliantly written pieces ever. It's just so good. It's so good and who better to deliver it than Rainn Wilson as Dwight. It was just perfect. I agree. There you have it everyone. That's frame Toby. Did you have anything else, Angela? I don't have anything else. I do want you guys to know
所有时间里最棒的。这话说得很有分量，因为有很多精彩的受访镜头，但这一个绝对能排进前五。他要描述他完美的犯罪计划。我觉得我们必须听听看。每次我看这一集，我都会被那句台词逗笑，而且我看了大概三遍。整个受访镜头都是按剧本写的，并且完全照剧本演了出来。我认为这是有史以来写得最精彩的片段之一。真的是太棒了。太棒了，由饰演德怀特的雷恩·威尔逊来表现，还有谁比他更合适呢。简直完美。我同意。大家听到了吧。这就是陷害托比。安吉拉，你还有别的要说的吗？我没有别的要说的了。不过我想让大家知道
because Jenna and I both watched the bloopers. Next week on the surplus was one of the hardest I've ever laughed in a scene. Oh, I can't wait. Thank you so much to Randy Cordray, James Carey, and Jen Salad and Paul Lieberstein. I traded some emails with them as well. Man, that was fun. That was a delight. I will be trying to clean my microwave using your method. Thank you. And we'll see you here next week. I'll be back in LA next week. I wonder will I bring New York Jenna home with me? We'll see. I don't know. New York Jenna might put the E next to our podcast. Sorry. What can I say? See you next week, guys. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Irwulf,
因为詹娜和我两个人都看了失误镜头。下周的《剩余预算》是我在拍戏时笑得最惨的一次。哦，我已经迫不及待了。非常感谢兰迪·科德雷、詹姆斯·凯里、詹·萨拉德和保罗·利伯斯坦。我也和他们交换了一些电子邮件。天哪，太有趣了。真是一大享受。我以后要试试用你的方法清理微波炉。谢谢。我们下周在这里见。我下周就要回洛杉矶了。我在想我会把“纽约詹娜”带回家吗？到时候看吧。我不知道。“纽约詹娜”可能会给我们的播客加上后缀。抱歉。我能说什么呢？大家下周见。下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由厄尔沃尔夫制作
Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkin. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科伊。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码Office。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。